[Music]
good morning Hank it's Friday May 18th
the day that I leave for my trip to the
Netherlands the Yeti and I are going to
the Netherlands to support my new novel
19 kir Catherine which I'm sure I'm
pronouncing extraordinarily well I'm
really excited about a trip to the
Netherlands I was supposed to go in
March but I got the orbital cellulitis
so I couldn't but now we are definitely
going unless I get a little cellulitis
again Hank this means that possibly I'll
get to meet some Brotherhood 2.0 viewers
who live in the Netherlands cross your
fingers maybe even to vyas to be us to
bias hmm
I'm not very good at pronunciation
speaking of pronunciation Hank it may
seem like you pretty well schooled me on
the pronounciation of Wikipedia I mean
you certainly have a lot of fact-based
evidence to support your assertion that
Wikipedia is supposed to be pronounced
Wikipedia or whatever I can't even
pronounce it the way you pronounce it my
tongue doesn't make those movements I
may not have facts on my side Hank but I
still think I'm right that's the
American Way and really what kind of
evidence do you have I mean you have
Wikipedia a known fraudulent source and
you have a girl robot voice saying
Wikipedia big deal I can get a girl
robot voice to say in my way Sarah Sarah
can you come in here can you say
Wikipedia in a robot voice come on
Wikipedia in a robot voice Wikipedia in
a robot voice Wikipedia see girl robot
voice saying Wikipedia checkmate
speaking of Wikipedia I'm trying I don't
know if you know this but your Wikipedia
entry has been oh damn it I don't know
if you know this but your Wikipedia
entry has been the subject of repeated
acts of vandalism many people have
changed your Wikipedia entry to say
quote he is a gay but one person went
further than that and said a lot of
truly offensive things that I can't
repeat on this vlog because of the
sensitive years of our younger listeners
I would however like to share with you a
couple of quick sentences from the
vandalism quote both him and his brother
John and gay
period um do you mean both he and his
brother John are gay because if you're
gonna vandalize Wikipedia you should do
it with some reference for the English
language the next sentence reads john
green's wife is a trans period
there's no apostrophe in the Greenes by
the way common term is ooh or my zoo or
Mitsu i don't know how to pronounce
anything says i don't care about how you
actually go about making a fiction book
proposal all i care about is that you
make the proposal using puppets misery
my zoo Mitsui i can't necessarily make
the proposal using puppets but I can
tell Hank about how to make a fiction
book proposal using puppets ok Hank
today we have playing the role of my
lovely editor julie strauss cable mr.
Argyle hey how are you guys good to see
you again ok and playing the role of me
we have our old friend
ubi hey fellas ok ok Julie we're just
gonna start out by talking a little bit
about a fiction book proposal um you're
not doing a very good job of moving your
hands right when you talk I know I know
I'm not um I'm not a puppeteer my
husband is a puppeteer I know but I
couldn't get him on such short notice
because um we're going to the
Netherlands can we just can we just get
on the thing yeah yeah very rarely do
you see a first novel cell on a proposal
they almost always have to have the
finished manuscript right I finished the
manuscript of Looking for Alaska
yeah but then when it came time for you
to create an abundance of katherines I
said why don't you send me a proposal
and you were like I don't know what a
proposal is I'm just a little Obie
exactly and I told you that a proposal
is basic sorry puppet fans I'm going to
run out of time Hank basically all you
need is a plot summary listed the
characters and then sample chapters so
they know what the book is actually
about and it's going to sound like all
right I really got to go to the airport
Hank I'll see you on Monday how you
birthday Katherine